(energetic jazzy music)
♪ I gotta smile and say I
hope you're feelin' better ♪
♪ And make believe it came from you ♪
- Hey guys, a lot of you have been
asking the question, can I cook?
And the answer really is, eh.
- You surprise me to how (beep) you are.
- I'm no Master Chef and
I think that's no secret
because you've seen my meal
prep video in the past,
which was really more of
like a snack prep video
rather than a true meal.
But today, you're gonna be cooking with me
an entire meal courtesy of Blue Apron,
a meal kit delivery service
which brings the
ingredients and the recipes
right to your door step.
Enough with the talking,
it's time to get serious.
Wait, is the flower in the shot?
(dramatic drumming music)
Probably don't need this right now.
Let's open the box first.
The first step to cooking a great meal
is picking out what you're gonna cook
and then picking up all the ingredients.
But thankfully we don't
have to do that today
'cause I have this box right here
that was delivered right to my door.
Let's get cooking!
So you have your chiller
bag, in case you're not home
the food stays cool with the ice.
The recipe we're gonna be cooking today
is the Tahini chicken with
crispy smashed potatoes
and snow pea tomato salad.
Let's take a look at what's
fully inside this box.
Knick Knacks, aka the sauces.
Got the radishes, very healthy vegetable.
Grape tomatoes.
Boneless, skinless chicken.
Snow peas.
Golden potatoes.
And a garlic bulb.
I got my ingredients and
I'm ready to start cooking.
But, I wanna get you your
own Blue Apron box deliver.
So down below in the description box,
I dropped a link, first
100 people who sign up
will get 50 bucks off their
first Blue Apron order.
Let's get cooking.
43 carbs with 6 sugars,
52 grams of protein
and a big highlight, trans fat is zero.
So the first part is gonna
be preparing the potatoes,
let me get my medium pot.
These are pots.
The medium would fall right in here.
Let's do something like
they do in clothing,
we'll go small, medium,
large, extra large.
Medium pot of salt and
water boiling on high.
That looked legit.
Wash and dry the fresh produce.
Produce washing kit.
Radishes, snow peas, grape tomatoes.
I don't know if this is the
right way to wash produce,
but it feels very efficient.
Large dice the potatoes.
I'm gonna operate on
these potatoes right now.
Yeah.
Advanced move, two potatoes in one.
Let's talk ingredients.
Radishes, what a rockstar vegetable.
They got vitamins A, E, C, B6, fiber.
Then you got your grape tomatoes,
which have been always
my favorite tomatoes
to eat because they're so bite sized
and crunchy, I love that.
They got lycopene which is a
really important antioxidant,
which has a lot of health benefits.
Add potatoes and cook for 11
to 13 minutes, while stirring.
But where's my cooking
spoon for the stirring?
Using a strainer, drain
the cooked potatoes
and pat dry with paper towels.
Strain, strain, strain,
strain, strain, strain.
Pat, pat, pat, pat, pat, pat.
Transfer to a cutting board,
using the flat side of your knife
carefully smash each potato
piece once to flatten.
They say a good chef
always tastes his food.
Half the peas crosswise.
Half the tomatoes.
Place in bowl and season
with salt and pepper.
Cut and discard the ends of the radishes.
Half lengthwise, then
thinly slice crosswise.
Look how green and colorful
this plate already looks.
Peel and finely chop the garlic.
Using the flat side of your knife,
smash until it resembles a paste.
In a large bowl, combine
the vinegar, tahini,
one tablespoon olive oil,
one tablespoon of water,
and as much of the
garlic paste as you like.
Season with salt and
pepper, whisk until smooth.
Fill a medium bowl with ice
water and a pinch of salt.
Set aside.
Add the half peas to the
pot of boiling water,
cook, stirring frequently.
Careful, coming through hot, hot, hot.
They say to immediately
put them in the ice water.
You know in medicine we
have to sometime shock
the patient, but right now the process
that I'd doing here is
called shocking the peas.
Pat the chicken dry with paper towels,
season with salt and pepper on both sides.
In a large pan, heat two
tablespoons of olive oil
on medium high until hot.
Throwin' the chicken on the pan.
(sizzling)
Can't handle the heat,
get out of the kitchen.
Ah!
That looks good.
Add the smashed potatoes in even layer,
season with salt and pepper,
cook four to five minutes per side,
until brown and crispy.
Imma be a potato Master Chef.
(fire alarm beeping)
No, it's not a fire!
Oh man, it's getting hot.
Oh man, it's getting hot!
(yelping)
Okay, switch gloves.
Now this glove is getting hot, Dan.
(groaning)
To the large bowl of dressing,
add the shock peas, seasoned
tomatoes, and sliced radishes.
(upbeat music)
Look at this creation.
That really does look like the picture.
Now the question is, does
it taste like the picture?
That's good.
Put the camera down, let's finish this
and we'll talk after, put it down.
That was a great meal.
I'm not even joking, like
10 out of 10 delicious,
and I cooked it by myself.
If I can do it, you definitely can do it.
More and more I find myself drifting away
from ordering take-out
and the more I find myself
wanting to prepare the meals on my own.
It's really critical to know
what goes into your foods.
I have patients that come in all the time
with worsening congestive heart failure,
or swelling in their legs, and I,
first question I ask them is
how much salt they're consuming
and most of them say well doctor
I don't salt my food at all.
But, then when I ask further,
they eat take-out quite often.
And when you eat take-out,
you just don't know
what you're getting.
I mean there's a whole host of things
that you don't know about how
your food is being prepared.
I always try to empower you at home,
and even my patients in the hospital
to take control of their health,
and an easy first step is to monitor
what foods you're eating
and watch those nutrition facts.
And with a service like Blue Apron,
they make it easy, no brainer.
I strongly encourage you,
go in my description box,
and click that link and
sign up for Blue Apron.
The first 100 people who sign up
will get 50 bucks off their
first two weeks of Blue Apron.
That's a no brainer.
Now I know you have some comments
or critiques about my cooking ability.
So go ahead, jump in the comments section,
I'm a big boy, I can take it.
Get down there also and ask your questions
because I'm active in the comments section
and every month I'm
still going to be doing
the Responding to Comments video.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(light jazzy music)